final and fourth story uh is about dc
because some of these places they're
just not stopping when it comes to kobe
they're actually getting even worse
this is a tweet from dc mayor bowser she
says remember that starting saturday you
will need these three things before
heading out proof of vaccination 12
years or plus
proof of vaccination and photo id 18
years and over and a mask now it's
interesting the way she worded that to
head out she didn't say to go into
government property she didn't say to go
into a restaurant she said to head out
that you have to basically have your
papers that's what she's saying we know
none of this nonsense works we know that
the vaccines don't stop you from getting
coveted we know that the vaccines don't
stop you from spreading covid
we know that people are just not paying
attention to these vaccines we know that
a higher percentage of black people have
not been vaccinated so is this racist we
also know that forcing someone to show a
vote uh some sort of photo id that's
we're always told that's racist if you
if you do it to make sure that people
are voting as the person that they say
they are but somehow uh if you show a
voter id or a photo id to walk into
mcdonald's you have to prove that you're
vaccinated but then you can eat the food
that'll make you fat which will make you
even sicker if you get cold
you guys get it yet you get it yet these
people are just ridiculous oh and of
course you know number three there was
the mass thing and it's like we're
they're telling us now that the masks
don't even work so now they've got
everybody in n95 so you just can't
breathe it's all insane so all this
leads me to this interesting compilation
video that i saw on twitter twitter just
about how badly the narrative has just
crumbled over the last two years take a
look i'm gonna shut down the virus i'm
gonna shut down the virus look there is
no federal solution that vaccinated
people do not carry the virus don't get
sick not going to get coveted if you
have these vaccinations people who've
been vaccinated are unlikely to get
coveted this is a pandemic of the
unvaccinated that's why i'm moving
forward with vaccination requirements
wherever i can break through infections
more breakthrough cases of covid19 we'll
leave vaccinated folks testing positive
that's going to be our new normal it
seems that more than half of the people
in the uk with the variant have been
double jabbed most are young people
under 40 years old nearly 80 percent
were vaccinated new concerns about the
omicron variants a record level of
children under the age of five are being
hospitalized amid a climbing infection
rates if you look at the children who
are hospitalized many of them are
hospitalized with covid as opposed to
because of covid and they get counted as
a covet hospitalized individual when in
fact they may go in for a broken leg so
it's over counting the number of
children who are quote hospitalized with
covid if you're attacking me you're
really attacking science i mean
everybody knows that you're really
attacking not only dr anthony fauci
you're attacking science 95 affected
this is our show brought to you by
pfizer this is the jj vaccine that i'll
be taking so one
and done
americans will need a third shot fourth
shot another booster talk about people
getting a fourth four i thought we're
just talking about three so a fourth
dose we are looking forward be able to
vaccinate all these vulnerable people
brought to you by pfizer
you get it yet
do you get it
yet i know you do but maybe send that to
some of your friends and family that do
not get it yet i will end by saying one
last thing which is that if you have
stayed remotely sane
in the last two years i applaud you like
if you manage to do it if you manage not
to fall for all the pitfalls and the
traps they set up if you manage to
use your own brain and think things
through and make decisions for yourself
and not become a hysterical lunatic i
applaud you and i look forward to
continuing our relationship as we blaze
a trail to a freer saner
and better america than than we got
right now